Speaker 1: Let's go next to Logan from
Kenosha, Wisconsin. Logan, you're on the air.
Hi, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right. Sorry, I'm in the car,
I just got out of class. You're doing great.
So I was just calling to ask the question
about 2020, for sure. Do you think it might be
better if it was Trump running, considering the
idea of turn out to vote against Trump,
like in 2020, it was more of a vote
against Trump than for Biden?
Speaker 1: You're saying, would it
be better for Democrats if Trump was the nominee?
Speaker 2: That's for Democrats like. Personally,
I think it would be worse for Democrats if
it was like DeSantis or someone like that.
Speaker 1: So here's my thought. This is a
really good question. If it's Biden versus Trump,
I think Trump wins. If it's Kamala versus
Trump, I think Trump wins. I think the one way
that it's better for Democrats, if it's Trump,
is if there is an actual sort of more inspiring
and dynamic Democratic nominee. I don't
know who that would be. I don't even know
if the person exists. But my point here is,
I think if it's seen as a rematch of 2020,
I think Trump wins if it's tired old, crazy Trump
again versus someone else. That's interesting. I
think in that case, it's better for Democrats, but
it's very, very risky. It's a risky proposition.
Speaker 2: Right. All right,
well, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, Logan from Kenosha. Great
to hear from you. That's going to do it for our
calls today. We will take calls again next week
and I look forward to hearing from you then.